but it's a great season October
Halloween we've got a line of merch
I mean is this the nicest thing you've
ever seen
Oh by far yeah top tier I
have never seen clothing like this in my
life I'm not kidding I'm not kidding
this isn't a joke
I've never seen clothing like this in my
life it's to me it's so
it's it's
it's epic and it stays
it's it's amazing and it can be worn in
all seasons in all climates
which many clothes cannot be
it is not a particular style
it's timeless
and it has a feeling no yes yeah yeah it
is I'm imagining someone 100 years from
now wearing it no it actually would work
yeah it actually will work and people
will wear it 100 years from now and
they'll speak of these days
and and
people will go
what was it like then and I'll go it was
a real nice fight out there or so we
were told
but it's it's really beautiful merch I
and and and and we are
you know going to be introducing this
very shortly and we're we're
hoping that people enjoy it
as much as we do because you worked very
hard now you emailed the designer I did
a few times so to me I I don't want to
understate his role
in the operation and what we do
so many people dismiss you because they
just look at what you do and go what
but really the reality of it is that
behind the scenes you're doing so much
and one of the things you've done
is send a three or four sentence email
to the designer of this merch with the
vision for the with the vision for the
merch that we both kind of came up with
right I think so right you had one I had
one right
and it's important to me that you buy
the merch
it really is it is it is important that
all of you listening by the merch
and I don't want to hear nothing
inflation's going down the price of gas
is going down I don't want to hear
nothing
I don't want to hear that your kid is
sick
your mother-in-law fell
the job's not what it used to be
the hours are getting crunched the
neighborhood's changing the taxes are up
the water's Brown you got a pain in your
lower back
I don't want to hear that you're
vomiting and [ __ ] more than you used
to that you wake up in the middle of the
night shivering
I don't want to hear that you don't have
anything to believe and your kids hate
you because you can't provide them with
the style of life that their friends
have I don't want to hear that you can't
get hard to [ __ ] your wife because she's
fat now because she's eating our poison
food
I don't want to hear that you can only
jerk off to women getting beaten on the
internet because you resent your wife
because she finished college and you
didn't
I don't want to hear that you have three
dogs and two of them need operations and
you can't afford it and one of them's
starting to smell
I don't want to hear that your father
doesn't look you in the eye because he's
ashamed of the man that you've become
I don't want to hear any of that
I want you to go buy this merch
and I want you to wear it
and all those problems are [ __ ]
minuscule when you're supporting a
podcast you like
do you enjoy
and people go what is that and you tell
them oh it's a show I like
I think how's your wife go let's talk
about something that's
beautiful
let's talk about art
let's talk about
a couple of guys that sit in a room and
do their hot takes every week that I
like I like it I like it it's my time I
sit in my car and I get high and I
listen to it and I drink and that [ __ ]
knows it's my time she doesn't come out
to see me and if she did man I picture
it I picture her coming out on that
front porch I picture her going stop
listening to that fat and raise your
kids and I said I'll just [ __ ] I'll
reverse right into that fat [ __ ]
but she never comes outside
because she's watching Betsy
she's watching Hillary Clinton
talk to a reverend about her very tough
decision to stay married
and she's drinking wine
in our back room and she can't even hear
me
and I'm out there tinkering in the
garage tinkering fixing it finding it
out and the kids they run by and I go
what are you doing and they go ah yeah
wow man they pay me no mind they pay me
no mind and
they pay me no mind
that's okay
that's okay because I got a pot I got a
podcast that I like
I got a podcast that I enjoy I got two
boys whose talk the [ __ ] I like I don't
care
what this family ends up doing this
family's not gonna produce generations
of wealth it's not gonna produce happy
people it will end my kids may not have
kids and if they have kids I worry even
more about it this will end it will end
in juvenile hall it will end in small
claims court it will end in Family Court
it will end with addicts with four days
of sobriety scraping the skin off their
arms trying not to [ __ ] go to the
7-Eleven parking lot and buy another
blue to just get them back to even it'll
end in a suburb of Schenectady New York
it'll end in Schoharie County it'll end
in Albany in the back of a catering hall
it'll end bad
it'll end at a funeral we can't afford
it'll end going into the ground with a
couple of bar buddies standing around
checking their watches it ends bad but
[ __ ] it I got a podcast today
with a couple of boys
and they're talking about Hillary
Clinton on the internet
and don't kid yourself that means
something to me because my family hates
me and I have no money and I wish I was
dead every minute of every day but today
I got a podcast to listen to and they
just said there's merch
they actually just said there's gonna be
merch
they said there's and my wife's gonna
fight about it because we have an
emergency only account like the last
time we used it is when my son was
accused of rape he didn't do it he was
dating a woman and she was Taking
Liberties with the truth and he was
accused of rape and we had to bail him
out this is before the Nobel law but
before the nobelo we had to bail my son
out who was accused of rape by his
on-again off-again girlfriend who said
he came over the house and had his way
with her and he assured us that he had
not done that but we had to bail him out
and we use the emergency fund the other
time we used it is when my car broke
down my wife was using my car she's a
server at a local rest stop
and she had to fix the car with the
emergency fund
we've reserved it for those types of
things son Sons problems and the wife
needing to get to work
but I swear to God
if I don't get that merch
if I don't support this guy
yes he has three houses he deserves
eight he deserves eight and I'll tell
that to my wife my fat wife when she
looks at me goes do you think he needs
more you don't know what he needs
he's not like us
he's not like us he was raised in a
different time in a different place
and this and this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] will look at me and she'll go
how dare you spend our [ __ ] money on
merch for this big this fat pig and I'll
say to her you know what
that's it
this ain't working
and she's gonna go we don't have enough
money for divorce I'm gonna go I'm not
talking about a divorce
this ain't working anymore none of it
the air the water the soil I feel like
I'm on an alien [ __ ] planet
so I'm going to take my Tim Dillon show
hoodie and I'm gonna put it on
and I'm gonna go out
and I'm gonna listen to Freebird in my
truck one more time and then I'm going
to blow my brains out and Drench that
hoodie and blood
and I'm gonna have you and the kids find
me you ungrateful grating and horrible
shrew
I'm gonna have you and the kids find me
and and the next day
like clockwork
they slept through the gunshot
because they were all [ __ ] up
on their sleeping pills and their booze
but they walked outside they didn't hear
the old man they didn't hear him
tinkering in the garage
they didn't hear him they didn't smell
the morning cigarette
they just went up to the car
and they saw the blood splattered all
over the front seat the old man was dead
but he was in his favorite merch
he was in the merch of his favorite
podcast and they buried him in it and
they fought with the Undertaker because
you're not going to bury him in a bloody
hoodie you go yes we are
bury him in that Bloody hoodie
so my hope is that no matter where you
are in your life
you buy this merchandise
because it is it is important and it is
beautiful
we put the time in Ben emailed the
designer
I was on the email as well I don't
really check the emails but I'm on it as
well
and if you're going to kill yourself in
front of your family
as many as I imagine many of you I
imagine 30 percent of the people who
listen to the show are going to do
exactly that
probably before New Year's
quite frankly
I just hope that you do it
in the Tim Dillon show merchandise
because it is beautiful
because there's here's one thing
it's gutsy
you know who Hillary Clinton should have
on that show Vince Foster's wife
I don't know if he was married he
probably was
we want to thank our friends at gas
digital Studios we want to thank what's
that what's your name the producer uh
Francis right
Francis I want to thank Francis
we want to thank all the moms and dads
out there and all the families that are
listening to this on their way to
Freedom Fest
all the families out there in this great
nation
you know I'm humbled and inspired every
day
when I hear about the stories of the
Medicare fraud and people that are
taking advantage of others and people
that are faking their own deaths I I'm
so happy that I say to myself you know
it's [ __ ] we're still fighting
we're still kicking we're still kicking
and that's beautiful but I think I've
done a decent job selling the merch
and we're gonna launch it soon
[ __ ] you can sign up at
timcomedy.com how about you go and sign
the [ __ ] up at timberlandcomedy.com you
go sign up right now because I'll tell
you right now
it's a b it's really beautiful